the idea for Amber lounge came up
because one year in Brazil we were all
driving around looking for a party to go
to it was the end of season you know
when there was about six drivers and you
know their entourage we just couldn't
find anywhere to go and I just thought a
lot of shame because on the whole
everyone gets on the idea was that would
be somewhere that people felt safe where
people could all go together of the same
ilk and have fun not worry about
pictures gone out to the press and media
so the lovely thing is that whenever you
come in down below the only people who
get in the under larger ones with the
pass I'm also old-fashioned in that I
have a dance floor and there's no roped
off areas which I didn't want I didn't
want or this is the VIP section this is
you can't go in there
I hate that actually kind him an old one
to the girl up and sing and the security
doesn't recognize room wouldn't matter
the back of the DJ booth which wasn't
particularly great there you go another
one people I think are really unique
we're a big family
we've got an absolutely zero tolerance
for time wasting and things not going
properly we work hard but we play hard